[Musik]
diese geschichte spielt im herzen
afrikas direkt unter dem äquator man
könnte meinen es sei ein reines paradies
[Musik]
in einem reservat leben hier 15 okapis
in gefangenschaft sie sollen später
einmal die zoos der welt exportiert
werden
rund herum erstreckt sich ein
naturschutzgebiet der lebensraum dieser
scheuen tiere
das okapi ist der nächste verwandte der
giraffe und wurde erst anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts entdeckt
die chefin hier ist rosmarie ruf aus der
schweiz sie hat das naturschutzprojekt
mit ihrem mann carey aufgebaut und sie
hat ihr leben diesem paradies aus
pflanzen und tieren gewidmet aus liebe
und ohne zu wissen was dabei auf sie
zukommt
sie kamen am 24 juni dieses jahres um
fünf uhr morgens und sie töteten alle
okapis durch das reservat zog sich eine
spur der verwüstung
sie zündeten alle häuser an und sie
schreckten auch vor dem letzten nicht
zurück sie ermordeten sechs menschen und
erschossen jeden der ihnen über den weg
lief ein ranger filmte die zerstörung
sie klauten aber es was nicht niet und
nagelfest war das lebenswerk von
rosmarie ruf in trümmern
für mich ist das eine katastrophe das
ist jetzt desaster ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen
dass das ist das wo nicht
danke aber rockstar wieso bin ich jemals
sie das land die noch wie sowieso heavy
so hemmer dass
der kongo ist so ist hart geschossen war
ich nur mir das land hole mir hat sehr
viel
elend bhc viel schicksalschlag
vermieden und er ist für das massaker
verantwortlich morgen satan er ist immer
noch herr freien fuß und er sucht nach
rosi morgen ist ein berüchtigter
wilderer der es vor allem auf das
elfenbein der waldelefanten abgesehen
hat waldelefanten die ebenfalls in
diesem reservat leben
die naturschützer haben morgen ins
handwerk gepfuscht
sie beschlagnahmten das elfenbein und
bekämpften die wilderei
das elfenbein werden zehn dollar pro
kilogramm gehandelt erzählt der park
verwalter dieser stoß zahlen der sieben
kilo wiege sei also immerhin 70 dollar
wert das sei natürlich viel geld für
jemanden der sonst nichts verdiene
ein paar wochen nach dem überfall wagte
sich rosmarie rolf wieder nach epu für
einen tag war sie zurück an diesem platz
der 25 jahre lang zu ihrer zweiten
heimat geworden war und der jetzt so
brutal zerstört ist wie es weiter gehen
soll war in diesem moment für alle
beteiligten unklar
[Musik]
dass das russian emi hofburg
es war ebenfalls ein trauriger anlass
als rosmarie ruhr von neun jahren
begegnete es war vor der abdankung für
jeden mann mit dem zusammen sie ein
halbes leben in afrika verbracht hatte
er wurde in roggwil beerdigt wo die
beiden eine kleine wohnung hatten seine
freunde waren gekommen zu diesem requiem
für kali
karl graf und seine zwei begleiter waren
bei einem autounfall in uganda gestorben
ein bus war ihrem wagen auf der falschen
straßenseite entgegen gekommen und so
endete das abenteuerliche leben des
naturschützers carlos in der banalität
eines frontalzusammenstoßes
carlo auf rosis mann den sie nur kari
nannten hatte freunde wo immer er war in
der schweiz in amerika und in afrika sie
alle waren hergekommen um noch einmal an
ihn zu denken
[Musik]
doch beginnen wir von vorne rosi um kari
hatten sich im basler zoo kennengelernt
wo caritas tierpfleger arbeitete und sie
auf dem büro gemeinsam wanderten sie
nach afrika aus auf kari
1979 eine stelle in zoo des präsidenten
mobutu im heutigen kongo an nahm die
geschichte eines großen gemeinsamen
abenteuers und die geschichte einer
großen liebe
schon damals
und
sie entdeckten afrika als neue heimat
und anfangs der 80er jahre kamen sie zum
ersten mal an den nettozufluss der zum
stromsystem des kongo gehört mitten im
riesigen die tore regenwald am äquator
[Musik]
hier war erst anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts das okapi als letztes
großes säugetier entdeckt worden
ein scheues alleine lebendes tier
kari und rosi begannen hier eine farce
station für okapis wieder aufzubauen die
im unabhängigkeitskrieg zerstört worden
war sie fingen und züchteten okapis um
die kleinen bestände in den zoos der
welt mit frischem blut zu versorgen
doch sie setzten sich nicht nur für
tiere ein sondern auch für die menschen
und jede umgebung sie waren glücklich
hier sie hatten hier so etwas wie ihre
bestimmung gefunden
[Musik]
ich glaube gott auf afrika mir jetzt
kein autos thema und die dank
naturbezogene
sachen müssen verzichten aber das hätte
ich gar nicht für uns gemacht
und ich denke dass mir richtig dass das
land oder der kontinent gar nicht
überall blüht
doch ende der 90er jahre wurde alles
anders als diese bilder aus dem kongo um
die welt gingen
es gab bis heute nach uno-schätzungen
gegen drei millionen tote und
hunderttausende von flüchtlingen das
okapi reservat so groß wie ein drittel
der schweiz wurde zeitweise zum
flüchtlingslager und schlachtfeld
zugleich
die einwohner der dörfer flüchteten und
versteckten sich im wald zwischen den
häusern bekämpften sich verschiedene
bürgerkriegs fraktionen noch heute
erinnern einschusslöcher an diese
schreckliche zeit
karl und rosi wurden selbst zu
flüchtlingen sie kämpften sich über die
schlechten straßen des itu die waldes
und sie reisten weg in die usa
[Musik]
dort fanden sie unterschlupf auf der
white rock plantagen bei ihrem sponsor
in florida in eine welt die ihnen
erscheinen musste wie eine hollywood
version von afrika warenhäuser und
savanne landschaften mit fließend kalt
und warmwasser swimmingpool und
erkundigten afrika in seiner hochglanz
version
hier werden verschiedene gefährdete
tierarten die man weiter züchtet um sie
vor dem aussterben zu bewahren
[Musik]
hier begegnete ich carl orff zum ersten
mal zwei jahre vor seinem tod
war an den reichen haut gilman geraten
als er geld für sein tierschutzprojekt
suchte und die stiftung von birnen
übernahm schließlich das ganze okapi
projekt
karl und rosi waren hier sozusagen im xl
direkt neben der villa des verstorbenen
mister kämen dessen stiftungen setzen
ein riesiges vermögen unter anderem für
den schutz gefährdeter tierarten 1
millionen gelder aus dem vermögen des
kinderlosen papier fabrikanten
in dieser umgebung aus reinem luxus
bewohnten kari und rosi ein haus mit
einer terrasse auf einer kleinen fluss
hinaus fast wie eine pool afrika nur
eben viel komfortabler es dort
super parade in
südafrika
hätte ist einfach bei die packung
für sie heimat
und uns
gibt es nur schönes haus in bushehr
it und planung tier und natur zu haben
2k bis leben hier auf der white rock
plantation in florida okapis di carli
und rosi aus afrika hierher gebracht
hatten die tiere dienen der züchtung für
die zoos in amerika und haben
mittlerweile 27 nachkommen
blutauffrischung
posierte mit demokratisch sagte mir kari
einmal und er mit den menschen
in new york hatte der reiche herkelmann
seine private arche noah eingerichtet es
werden verschiedene tiere gezüchtet und
den zoos zur verfügung gestellt so so
die art erhalten werden
hier wird an nichts gespart es arbeiten
veterinäre tierpfleger zu logen und für
die tiere steht eine bestens
eingerichtete klinik zur verfügung ein
gepard beim check up
der in der schweiz metzger gelernt hatte
bevor er die wörter und schließlich
naturschützer geworden war staunte immer
wieder über diesen ganzen aufwand
verdient
ich schon groß
sehr groß
[Musik]
es ist einfach alles vorhanden
die die haut gegangen
kongo ist
richtiges rechten getan
allerdings wären die tiere hier mit
modernsten mitteln aufgepäppelt werden
damit sie sich möglichst gut vermehren
geht ihre natürliche umgebung kaputt
darum wurde für kali der schutz der
lebensräume immer wichtiger
ab und zu kehrten kali und auch rosi
zurück in den kongo wo jetzt krieg
herrschte
die ranger des okapi reservates
patroullieren jetzt durch ein
eigentliches kriegsgebiet das
fatalerweise reich an bodenschätzen ist
bodenschätze und deren verteilung es in
diesem krieg letztendlich gibt
die parkwächter fühlen uns zu illegalen
goldgruben wie sie überall im
naturschutzgebiet entstanden sind
[Musik]
brück suche aller art sind in schwung
gekommen zu viele leute und zu viele
waffen im paradies
khalili stranger von apple sogar
militärisch ausbilden und machte selber
mit sein zweites soldatische training
nach der rekrutenschule dieses mal mit
der kalaschnikow
zwischendurch verhandelte er mit
generellen und rebellen führen damit sie
ihre soldaten die ständig zu wenig zu
essen haben daran hinderten die tiere im
reservat abzuknallen
doch alle mühe war schließlich vergebens
was er mit seinem engsten mitarbeitern
durch das kriegsgebiet zurück nach
uganda starb er ironischerweise nicht
durch eine kugel sondern an diesem
simplen verkehrsunfall
das muss probieren zu machen will ich
denke es war ungewohnt sie
das projekt aronian wieder gott
und ich habe mich dann entschlossen
der lichtwoche sportlichen tag später
also probieren das projekt bietet wäre
und versuchen sie sehen
in der politik fahren
so ging rosa so zurück in den kongo flog
mehr als 200 kilometer über den
undurchdringlichen dschungel des
regenwaldes zurück nach polen wo sie
mich sagt karin am nächsten sei
sie landete auf der kleinen piste di
carli hatte anlegen lassen
und sie wurde hierzu managerin des
ganzen projektes eine rolle die sie nie
gesucht hatte denn wie gesagt sie sprach
mit den tieren und kari mit den menschen
[Musik]
kommentator
ich habe zu metro
kommt der hahne chrome
[Musik]
v
do
was ist denn los als ich
15 okapis werden bei polo in
gefangenschaft gehalten später wenn die
politische lage besser sein wird sollen
sie wieder gezüchtet und in die zoos der
welt exportiert werden allerdings nur
solche tiere die auch in gefangenschaft
geboren sind
ab und zu geht rosi hinaus in den
dschungel zusammen mit einem führer und
übersetzte
sie besucht die pygmäen in ihrem dorf
denn die pygmäen sind die wichtigste
informationsquelle über alles was im
sommer passiert
sie kennen die wege der tiere sie wissen
wo gebildet wird sie sehen den spuren im
walde an wo soldaten rebellen oder
goldsucher unterwegs waren
verwaltet und geschützt wird das okapi
reservat vom staatlichen kongolesischen
naturschutz institut icc
unterstützt durch ausländische geldgeber
[Musik]
doch rossi will nicht nur managerin sein
jeden morgen versorgt sich selber jenes
okapi dass nach dem tod von kari auf die
welt kam und dass sie kauften nach den
anfangsbuchstaben von karlsruhe das ist
auch so etwas wie ihr persönlicher
andacht für diesen erinnerung in dem
projekt weiterlebt
struktur
ist irgendwie immer noch da genauso wie
die trauer über seinen tod und das ende
dieser großen liebe
[Musik]
heute neun jahre später ist alles
zerstört
die häuser der parkverwaltung abgebrannt
die tiere tot und rosi weit weg in der
schweiz
in der schweiz ist sie sicher denn die
attentäter im kongo hatten auch nach ihr
gesucht
wir fahren mit ihren jenen ort wo diese
ganze geschichte begonnen hat in den
basel zu
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und das geht dann auch
hier erinnert sie alles an afrika und
jede gemeinsame geschichte mit karte
der zoo basel gehört zu den sponsoren
des eu projektes und der zoodirektor
will dass es dort auch weiter geht also
ich bin optimistisch dass es wieder gab
es die auch bedruckt vor dem
lokal basiert wird und auch vom vom
villa vor der blüte oder verantwortlich
sind wo zeigt sie soll warnt dass es
weitergeht und wir können einen beitrag
leisten dazu wie hast du's wieder in
afrika
das ist schwarz
ich glaube wir
machen nur gewisse die ganze lage
entwickelt hat und wo ganz kurze
zeitspanne
programmieren aber nicht für lange zeit
will das kann ich im moment nicht aber
wie optimistisch ja so 50 50 match im
moment so glücklich wieder
zurückgegangen trocken
vor einem monat ist rosi wieder nach
afrika abgereist und so beginnt sie noch
einmal von vorne diese unendliche
geschichte
[Musik]
das teenie team